JT's with us an Idaho hi JT how are you
good how are you Dave it's great to talk
to you you too what's up so I and I have
this idea for a business I'm trying to
start a small business but my wife isn't
really on board with it and I just maybe
she's right and I'd like to get your
opinion on it why is she not on board
what does she know I like she doesn't
she doesn't like this startup cost
because of our situation and and also
the time that I would need to invest
into it I'm currently pursuing a major
in web design and development I have a
minor in business entrepreneurship and I
have online marketing experience and
what I want want to do is basically just
become a reseller for various companies
whereas I'm a web developer I can throw
together a nice website ecommerce
website begin reselling for different
companies I already have a couple that
would love for me to sell their products
what is the what's all the startup cost
it's not much honestly and I told her I
just I really wanted to start with this
one company that I feel really what is
the startup cost it's less than $200 I'm
confused about why that's a problem that
I am - we're on track to pay off all of
our debt that's January and almost you
how much debt do you have we have uh
$3500 and what's your household income
um between ten and twelve thousand a
year as a student I work part-time
mostly okay I think I just found our
problem there isn't anything to do with
the with the business that you want to
start it's got to do with the fact
you're starving to death yeah I mean
this is why I'm trying to do this so
that we so that I can have a side income
she did she stays at home we have one
baby and we have one baby on the way in
January okay when will you finish your
degrees I will finish my degree in that
spring of 2018 and you plan on living
like this until then until then yeah
that's her problem
she's tired of starving to death the
same let's say working man I mean you're
living way below the poverty level yeah
it's because it going to school
full-time
doesn't give me much time to work and
keep my grades up so I basically only
during school I work 20 to 30 hours a
week um their jobs if I work if I work
any more than that I you know my grades
come down yeah your job sucks and you're
really bad at planning your time too
because I worked 40 to 60 hours a week
and went through a four year got a four
year degree in four years I worked like
an animal and and I made a lot more
money than that and it was a long time
ago so like 35 years ago so you know you
need a different job you need to make
more money and if you want to do this on
the side that's fine but you know what
what she's really trying to say is she's
kind of tired of your schemes because
she's tired of starving yeah and so you
guys have a tremendously large income
problem and you need to address that
with two babies before we worry about
you graduating from school even well I
mean you need to get your income up even
if you quit school you need to get your
income up dramatically up and then work
your way through school taking it at
night if it takes you a few years longer
but if you can't find something to
triple or at least double your income
and work more hours and still get
through school then you need to rethink
this process because you got a wife and
two children they're starving man she's
scared to death dude yeah oh and what
what do you think that the this new
business
could do that no no I think the new
business can do that as a side thing if
you get the other stuff if you get
something else going but right now
you've got a primary responsibility
rather than hoping that a reseller on
the Internet which a lot of that Sasuke
I'm people pull it off but there's a lot
of people selling the idea of being a
reseller more than actually doing
reselling and so I mean you've been
reading stuff on the on the internet is
where you've got that and so I know I
mean I think you get out there and you
scratch around you find a way to make
some money now if you want to try this
and say okay here's what we're going to
do I'm going to go crazy on this idea
I'm gonna spend $200 and a lot of time
and I'm going to get our income up and
if it come doesn't come up in two months
honey we're going to have to rethink
this because I know you're tired of
starving and I'm tired of starving and
because dude this is an untenable thing
you're doing here I mean it's just not
it's not reasonable to your family you
have got to get your income up so if you
want to give it like 60 days or
something and go okay from now than the
year we're going to sprint you know 90
days whatever right from down to the end
year we're going to sprint we're going
to October November December we're gonna
give it everything we got but January 1
if I haven't made substantial money on
this reselling thing in addition to the
hours I'm working at my little bad job I
god then we're going to relook what I'm
doing for a living and how we're
providing for this family because I'm
going to get our income up baby and I
know you're tired of starving and then
you spend the $200 and you plow in and
you give it everything you got for 90
days and prove me wrong and if you want
I'm okay you might go make a hundred
thousand bucks I don't care I hope you
do but I am NOT that enthused about the
idea it's an okay idea some people do it
and make money a lot of people just kind
of get screwed around on it by the
internet get-rich-quick scheme type
thing so be careful with it and don't
spend any more than a couple hundred
bucks don't get yourself into a bunch of
debt buying product that you haven't
sold and that kind of thing if you're
simply doing reselling you know dropship
stuff that's fine give it a shot tear
into it give it everything you got on
web marketing use all the
tools you've been given and and you know
put a bunch of hours in it she and the
baby goes go babies go to bed you you're
up and you work it you work it and you
work it you work it you work it the
first book financial piece was written
at 10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m. in the
mornings
that's a many many nights Sharon and the
kids went to bed old Dave sitting there
packing away because I had a belief that
that book was going to be something I
was right sometimes a lot of people said
I wasn't going to be right so I hope
you're right but give it a shot and then
if it doesn't you have to address this
income issue living like you're living
from now until 2018 is not okay hope I
wasn't unclear JT thanks for the call
man we appreciate you joining us hey
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you enjoyed
that video from the Dave Ramsey show if
you want to watch another great video
check out my video three things you
should consider rinsing right over here
or click the link in the description
below